- So MSCHF Product Studios
teamed up with rapper, Lil Nas X
to modify some Nike shoes
that were made with a splash
of real human blood.
Nike says just don't do it.
And following in the
footsteps of cultural icons
like 17th century poet, John
Milton and Madonna, the singer,
not the other one,
Lil Nas X dropped a music video
where he evokes Satan's fall
into hell by descending into
hell himself via stripper pole.
I don't think that is
actually in "Paradise Lost".
But along the way, Lil Nas X wears
modified Nike Air Max 97s.
MSCHF Product Studio was
responsible for modding the shoes,
adding occult references like 666,
a pentagram, Bible verses in red ink.
Oh, and of course, the midsole
of each shoe contains exactly
one drop of human blood.
But when MSCHF offered 666
pairs of shoes for sale,
Nike responded quickly by suing MSCHF
for trademark infringement.
So the question is what
the hell is going on?
(triumphant music)
Sponsored by Skillshare
Hey, Legal Eagles.
It's time to think like a lawyer
because the devil is in the details.
And what is going on with this suit?
What does it mean for
sneaker heads in general?
Is it illegal to modify a
consumer product and resell it?
Does this mean that you can't
sell modified Nikes anymore,
or any other kind of modified clothing?
Well, we're going to get
into all of that today
because this is a fascinating
case that just involves
just about everything.
But first a point of clarification
because a lot of people
think that this case
involves copyright and
that's simply not the case.
There are generally three
kinds of intellectual property
or IP that people think about.
There's copyright patent and trademark.
Copyright involves things
that are expressive.
Things like art, books, TV shows, movies,
that gets copyright protection.
Then there's patents.
That tends to cover useful
items, things like inventions.
And then finally, that leaves trademark,
which is meant to protect
the consumer public.
It's meant to show
people where things came
from by creating brands so
that they know the source
of the things that they are buying.
And in order to qualify
for trademark protection
under federal law,
a trademark has to meet
three basic requirements.
One, the trademark has to
be distinctive of the source
of the goods or services
to which it is affixed.
Number two, the trademark
must not be disqualified
from protection by various
statutory bars to protection.
And number three, the trademark
has to be used in commerce.
The purpose of trademark
is to identify the source
of goods to ensure that consumers
actually know where
their products come from.
In other words, trademark
holders get protection
from people and companies who
would sell knockoff goods.
It's all about protecting
the consumer public.
And that's what this
whole lawsuit is about.
Nike has invested billions
of dollars into its brand,
and is trying to protect the strength
of the Swoosh and the Nike word mark
so that people aren't confused
and people don't think that
Nike created some shoes
that are endorsed by Satan.
You can sort of understand
where they're coming from on that.
And in Nike's lawsuit, it
immediately dissociates itself
from the Satan Shoes.
Quote, "MSCHF is currently taking orders
for the shoes it refers
to as these Satan Shoes,
which are customized Nike Air Max 97 shoes
that MSCHF has materially
altered to prominently feature
a satanic theme.
This was done without Nike's
approval or authorization.
And Nike is in no way
connected to this project."
So Nike brings a bunch of claims.
And the first of which is garden variety
trademark infringement in
violation of 15 U.S.C. 1114.
And Nike claims that
MSCHF products violated
Nike's trademark by manufacturing
and selling Satan Shoes.
So how do you prove
trademark infringement?
Well, to prevail on a claim
of trademark infringement,
the company has to show one,
it owns a valid trademark.
Number two, that the
defendant used the trademark
in commerce without the company's consent.
And three, the defendant's
use created a likelihood
of consumer confusion.
The key element is the third one,
that there is a likelihood that
a consumer will be confused
about the source of the goods.
And Nike objects, that it has no control
over the nature and
quality of the Satan Shoes,
and that it has a reputation and goodwill
that will be damaged
if MSCHF keeps selling
these modified Nikes.
And consumers are likely to be confused
by the shoes, and any
defects, objections, or faults
with the shoes that might
hurt Nike's reputation.
And Nike, of course,
especially objects to the blood
in the midsole, which
could pose a risk of harm
to the consumer.
But this isn't your garden variety
trademark infringement case
where some nefarious competitor
is creating another product,
intentionally creating it in a way
that's confusing to people,
creating a bunch of shoes
that have a check mark on it
that kind of looks like a Nike Swoosh.
Instead, MSCHF actually bought Nikes.
They were originally Nikes.
It's just that they modified
them after the fact.
Which brings up the most common
defense in a case like this,
which is called the first sale doctrine.
When people started hearing
about this Nike suit,
a lot of people were
worried that that meant
that if Nike can sue you,
you can't buy a consumer good
and then resell it,
let's say used on eBay,
or maybe resell it new on Amazon.
But generally, the first sale doctrine
means that it's legal for an individual
to resell a trademarked item
after it has been sold
by the trademark owner
in an authorized sale.
So when you buy an
authentic pair of Nikes,
you can usually do what
you want with them.
In fact, anytime you buy a
branded good, it becomes yours.
If you want to buy a book
and later sell it on eBay,
the author can't stop you.
You can keep it forever
and maybe give it to
Goodwill, sell it on eBay,
or throw it in a lake.
It's yours to do with what you want.
And trademark law is
supposed to protect consumers
from being deceived about
the origin of a product.
Are consumers confused when
they buy the genuine article
with an authentic trademark?
Generally, no, they're not.
And that's why a
mark-holder can't stop you
from reselling a used item.
That's the whole purpose
of the first sale doctrine.
And there are a couple of exceptions
to the first sale doctrine.
For the purposes of Nike's lawsuit,
the most important one
applies when the products sold
are materially different
from the company's authorized product.
Nike says that its shoes were materially
altered to prominently
feature a satanic theme.
And so how do you prove
material difference?
Well, in 2020, one court
described it this way.
An alteration is material
if it changes something about
the product that is relevant
to a consumer's decision
to purchase that product.
That quote is from a case where Maui Jim,
the sunglass manufacturer,
sued someone who was
reselling their sunglasses,
but they removed the
lenses from the frames
and replace them with different lenses.
Generally, either plano
lenses or prescription lenses.
The problem from Maui Jim's perspective
was that they had patented the lenses
to promise to wipe out glare and UV rays.
And the Skin Cancer Foundation
officially recommended
the Maui Jims as an effective UV filter
for the eyes and surrounding skin.
So Maui Jim didn't want people buying
these modified sunglasses
without the protections
that they had designed into
their original glasses.
And Maui Jim successfully
argued that by replacing
the lenses with something else,
this reseller had removed
something that factored
into a person's decision
to buy Maui Jim frames.
So to bring it back around
to these Satan Shoes,
Nike is arguing that
confusion has already resulted
because this unauthorized reseller
and modifier of shoes is
offering original Nike shoes
without the associated benefits
that Nike customers expect.
And it has been materially modified.
Nike says that adding an extra substance
like blood to the midsole
of the shoe could pose
safety risks to the consumer.
And of course, Nike also implies
that lots and lots of
consumers are disgusted
by the ideas of shoes with blood in them.
And yeah, if you're selling Nike Air Shoes
they're supposed to have an air pocket
in the sole of the shoe,
and it's actually filled with liquid,
regardless of whatever that liquid is,
that kind of seems like
a material difference.
But Nike's second claim is for
false designation of origin,
which is generally a fancy
name for consumer confusion.
According to Nike,
consumers are already
being misled into believing
that Nike was deliberately
promoting Satan Shoes.
The company can cite hundreds of posts
from Christians who are now questioning
whether Nike is promoting Satan.
They can also find plenty
of people who object
to having shoes made with blood in them.
And I have to admit, when
I first saw the headlines
for this case, I thought Nike
had manufactured the shoes.
There's a prominent white
Nike Swoosh on a black shoe.
I thought that Nike had
done this collaboration.
And as Nike says,
"As an innovative brand that
strives to push the envelope
and do the right thing,
Nike knows it may not
please everyone at all time,
but decisions about what products
to put the Swoosh on belong to Nike."
But on the other hand, generally,
when you're talking
about consumer confusion,
you're talking about
point of sale confusion,
that the people who
bought the actual products
were misled into thinking
that there was some association there.
And it's actually sort of
unlikely that the over 600 people
that bought the modified
shoe thought that Nike
had created the shoe.
It seems like they knew
that MSCHF was the one
that modified those shoes.
So it's hard to argue
that they, the consumers,
the direct consumers of
these shoes were confused
in any other way.
Though, on the other other hand,
Nike would argue
that regardless of whether
these consumers were confused,
downstream consumers, the public at large
will think that Nike had something
to do with those Satan Shoes
and thus potentially not buy
Nike shoes in the future.
And then we get to Nike's third
and my favorite trademark related claim,
one for trademark dilution.
And I know I joke on this channel
a lot about claims
being particularly sexy,
but this claim is actually literally sexy.
And we'll get to that in just a second.
But in 1996, Congress enacted
the Federal Trademark Dilution Act,
which made it possible for mark-holders
to obtain injunctions against
the use of their marks,
even if there is no traditional
trademark infringement.
And the FTDA gives certain mark-holders,
the right to sue when a
third-party uses a mark
in commerce in such a way that
it hurts consumer perception
of a famous mark.
And they're generally
two kinds of dilution,
there's blurring and there's tarnishment.
And blurring is when a
famous mark's distinctiveness
is harmed because it becomes
or is likely to become
associated with a similar
mark in a different context.
So for example, if Rolex
was suddenly stamped
on golf balls and hotdogs,
in addition to watches,
then there would be blurring of that mark.
You might associate Rolex with hotdogs
instead of fancy watches.
And tarnishment, on the other hand,
happens when the famous
mark's reputation is harmed
through an association.
Tarnishment creates a harm
to a famous mark by
associating it with something
that would damage that reputation.
So normally, that's when
a famous mark is linked
with something that is
considered offensive
like pornography or drug use.
And courts are especially
hard on expressions that link
a product to sex.
(sexy music)
I told you,
we were going to get actually sexy
with this legal claim.
So for example, Barbie won a case
against a porn company
that wanted to have Barbie
in their URL.
And the Dallas Cowboy
Cheerleaders won a case
against the movie, "Debbie Does Dallas"
because it used Dallas Cowboy
Cheerleader style outfits
in a very adult film.
And a website was not allowed
to use the domain name
candyland.com to identify a
porn site because it tarnished
and diluted the Hasbro
Candyland trademark associated
with its board games.
But if the subject is not sex,
then courts are not completely
consistent in how they decide
whether there is actual
tarnishment and dilution.
So for example, in one case,
parodies involving dog chew
toys were protected speech.
The Ninth Circuit held that a
squeaking dog toy resembling
a bottle of Jack Daniel's
Whiskey is an expressive work
entitled to First Amendment protection.
While a Virginia court held
that Louis Vuitton's
mark was not tarnished
by a company selling Chewy
Vuitton squeaky dog toys.
But on the other hand, Dr. Seuss
was able to stop publication
of an OJ Simpson trial parody book
called "The Cat Not in
the Hat", by Dr. Juice.
The court found the likelihood
of confusion and stopped publication.
That case involved both
copyright and trademark aspects.
You really could write a whole book
on how Dr. Seuss Enterprises
vigorously defends its
rights through lawsuits.
But in contrast, the
band, Aqua was victorious
in a battle with Mattel over
the song, "Barbie Girl",
where the Ninth Circuit held that the song
about Barbie did not turn
Barbie into a sex object,
nor did its lyrics tarnish
Barbie's reputation.
But Nike claims had MSCHF's wrongful use
of the Nike asserted marks in connection
with these satanic imagery
is likely to cause
dilution by tarnishment.
Which understandably, could theoretically
damage Nike's reputation.
And as I said, courts take
a very puritanical view
when it comes to associations with sex,
but we don't know exactly what
the court's going to think
about using satanic imagery on a shoe,
whether that's offensive or unsavory
in the same way that pornography
or criminality would be.
But Nike probably has a decent
chance of prevailing on this.
So let's talk about MSCHF's defenses here.
In its response to Nike's motion
for a temporary restraining order,
which I'll get to in a few moments,
MSCHF says that Nike cannot show confusion
among sophisticated
purchasers of sneakers,
who all knew all along
that this was a collab
between Lil Nas X and MSCHF,
with no Nike involvement.
But Nike's counter to
this is that Nike's logo
is all over the shoes in question.
And as for Nike's claim that
its brand is being tarnished
by an association with Satan,
MSCHF argues about the
prior shoes that it created.
It created a line of Jesus Shoes,
white shoes with cross iconography
and filled with supposedly
blue holy water,
and says that those shoes
were not universally embraced,
but Nike didn't try it
and enforce their rights
against that particular modified shoe.
And on the contrary,
many people were outraged
by the these Jesus Shoes and
labeled them as sacrilegious.
And like Nike, MSCHF has
tweets backing up its position.
And here's one pointing out that Nike
is named for the Greek Goddess of Victory,
which at least one Twitter
user found to be offensive.
And here's one saying that the Jesus shoes
made the user sick,
and he intended throw
away all of his Nike gear.
So Nike can't win with associations
with other non-satanic deities.
And MSCHF's point here is that
they can probably find tweets
hammering Nike no matter
what choice they make.
And people have criticized Nike
for manufacturing sneakers in China.
But when Nike criticized
China's forced labor
camps earlier this year,
Chinese celebrities publicly
cut ties with the company.
So Nike is frequently the subject
of debate and controversy.
Those who are convinced
Nike is a horrible company
are unlikely to be swayed
by the Satan Shoes.
And that, of course, brings
us to the First Amendment
because just because
something is a trademark
or is involved in commerce doesn't mean
that you give up all
First Amendment rights.
Trademarks, of course,
are meant to protect
against consumer confusion.
But in recent years, courts
are increasingly likely to find
that the First Amendment protects speech,
even when it might naturally
result in some confusion.
And that's a good thing for artists
like Lil Nas X and MSCHF.
Nike of course, claims
that the Satan Shoes
are not a piece of of art,
and we're not created by artists,
and are just purely a commercial venture.
Saying, while MSCHF has
a First Amendment right
to criticize discriminatory social norms,
those norms have nothing
to do with the Nike Swoosh
and the Nike word mark.
But at base, there's clearly some tension
between trying to protect trademarks
and one's First Amendment
right to expression,
which takes us to the parody defense.
Just as fair use is a defense
to copyright infringement,
parody is a defense
to some kinds of
trademark dilution claims.
But parody in the trademark
context is not easy to prove.
The elements that you
have to show are one,
an original host work.
Two, the original work must be famous
or well-known within the
particular target audience.
And three, of the creator
of the derivative work,
the parody must take only
so much of the original work
as is necessary to bring to
mind the original host work.
And four, the derivative work,
which conjures up the famous mark
must result a new, original work.
So let's break this down further.
This is difficult in this context
because the parody has to be making fun
of a real product here, Nike shoes.
It can't just be a parody
of something else like
religion, for example.
And it has to be obvious to consumers
that the parody is making a
comment on the real product.
And the second message
must be something like,
yes, these are authentic Nike shoes,
and isn't Nike ridiculous
with the way that they use their brand?
So there has to be an
element of satire, joking,
or a irreverent commentary
that the consumer would understand.
And this is a really interesting issue
for MSCHF because as
we talked about before,
a traditional trademark case cares
about confusion at the point of sale.
Were the people who bought
the Satan Shoes confused
at all about the source?
Probably not.
The buyers knew that
MSCHF had created a parody
making fun of Nike itself.
The argument being that they're making fun
of all the collaborations
that Nike is willing to do
that they'll basically
collaborate with anyone,
even Jesus or Satan.
And there are collectors
who are well aware
of what MSCHF does.
In fact, they may even be aware that MSCHF
once made Jesus Shoes
with holy water in the midsole,
and Nike didn't object.
And the Jesus Shoe is interesting
because it added a golden Jesus
on a crucifix as a shoelace charm,
and MSCHF also sourced holy
water from the River Jordan,
which was apparently blessed
by a priest in Brooklyn
and added it to the sole of the shoe.
And in a press release,
MSCHF founder said that he was commenting
on the ridiculous collaborations
that Nike has done.
"We asked ourselves,
what would a shoe collab
with Jesus actually look like?
Obviously, it would let you walk on water.
Well, how can we do that?
And you pump holy water
into the pocket of air
of the Air Max 97s.
And with that, you get the Jesus Shoe,
the holiest collab ever."
And that makes the Jesus Shoe
and the Satan Shoes
feel more like a parody.
Maybe the Satan Shoe buyers were aware
of this history of weird
collabs and even saw Satan Shoes
as an extension of the
earlier Jesus Shoes.
Counsel for MSCHF
expanded on this argument
in the company's TRO
letter, where MSCHF argues
that the shoes aren't mocking religion,
they are mocking Nike's reputation.
And Nike is at once a
global icon and a company
with a reputation for
shady business practices,
like making shoes using
Chinese sweat shops,
and collaborating with just
about anyone to make a buck.
But this logic may not hold up in court.
Nike can respond by saying that sure,
the 666 consumers who purchased
the shoes weren't confused,
but everyone else on
the internet surely was.
And these people matter
because they are future Nike
consumers who are now confused.
They are literally saying,
"Oh no, Nike loves Satan.
I have to burn my Nike's again."
And that takes us to the motion
for a temporary restraining order.
Nike was lightening
fast with this lawsuit,
filing almost the next day
after the shoes were released.
And the day after that,
Nike moved for a temporary
restraining order,
or an injunction to prevent MSCHF
from doing anything related
to the shoes basically.
Nike wanted a temporary
and permanent injunctive
to prevent MSCHF from
manufacturing, transporting,
promoting, advertising,
publicizing, distributing,
ordering for sale, or
selling any products,
including but not limited
to these Satan Shoes
under Nike marks
and/or any marks substantially
indistinguishable therefrom.
Now, we've talked about
TROs a lot on this channel.
Generally, the court only will
issue this emergency relief
when there is irreparable harm that cannot
be undone by the court.
Generally, the idea is if you
can be compensated with money,
even long after the fact,
that's not irreparable harm.
But IP is an area where courts
often find irreparable harm.
It's harm to one reputation or
brand that cannot be undone.
And that's what Nike is saying here,
that their brand is being tarnished-
(woman screaming)
by an association with Satan.
And you can't really
undo that after the fact.
But MSCHF argues that
this is inappropriate
because MSCHF has already
shipped 665 of its 666 pairs
of shoes, with only one
pair of being held back
for a later raffle.
But it contends that since the
shoes have already shipped,
they've gone out, emergency
relief shouldn't be granted.
Well, Nike responded
that even if the company
did all but one of the pairs of shoes,
the TRO would still be
necessary to prevent
that one other pair of shoes going out
and to prevent MSCHF from
benefiting from this harmful
and tarnishing action that
they've taken against Nike.
And Nike accuses MSCHF,
probably correctly,
of quickly shipping the
orders to circumvent
the possible incoming TRO.
And to add injury to insult,
MSCHF is now selling a T-shirt bearing
the front page of Nike's
complaint on the shirt.
That is some creative marketing there.
And of course, Nike accused MSCHF
of deliberately trying
to stir up controversy
by promoting the T-shirt and going forward
with the shoe sale,
despite having noticed that Nike believed
that this was trademark infringement.
But at the same time,
Nike didn't technically notify MSCHF
by letter or phone call, that
had objected to the shoes.
The company just simply
went forward with a lawsuit
on the same day of the sale.
But just like Nike,
the court moved lightening fast.
And within a day,
issued a temporary restraining order,
preventing MSCHF from really
doing anything related
to the shoes.
But here, it's hard to unring the bell.
The shoes are out.
MSCHF has really benefited
from all of the publicity
that it has gotten related
to the Satan Shoes.
And the associations have been made.
Now, the court hasn't made a determination
on the merits, a final one.
It found that Nike was likely to prevail
if this indeed goes forward,
but MSCHF will be able to
present all of its arguments,
even those related to the
First Amendment issues
in briefing related to
a preliminary injunction
and eventually, the trial itself.
But if you want to shoot
a Satan-themed music video
that may or may not be a parody,
you'll need to learn how
to shoot great video.
And no one does that
better than my friend,
Marques Brownlee who a new class
on Skillshare called "Script,
Shoot, & Edit with MKBHD".
From initial concept to final cut,
Marques will share his creative process,
production workflow, and
favorite tools like never before.
Or if you want to learn how
to make your own Satan Shoes,
you could take Gigi Rodgers's class,
"Sneaker Customizing for Beginners."
And if you want to write
a blasphemous song,
you can learn how to play guitar
on Skillshare with my
friend, Mike Boyd's class.
Because Skillshare has
classes on almost everything,
from video to business to design.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything.
And it's the best place
to learn on the internet.
So if you'd like to try out Skillshare,
the first 1000 Legal
Eagles to use the link
in the description will get a free trial
of Skillshare Premium.
And after the trial
ends, Skillshare is still
way more affordable than most
online learning platforms
with plans starting at
less than $10 per month.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So just click on the
link in the description
to get a free trial of Skillshare Premium.
But what do you think, is
Nike going to sue MSCHF
out of existence?
Or is MSCHF just engaged
in First Amendment protected parody?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
where I talk about the
legal issues of the day,
including all of this
crazy IP-related stuff.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.